last week the Islamic state group was
all over the news after beheading
American journalist James Foley this
week an American has died fighting for
them 33 year-old Douglas MacArthur
McCain was from San Diego California the
McCain is not the first American to die
fighting in Syria and Syria isn't the
only place where US citizens have been
killed fighting for foreign armies this
summer
in July two Americans serving in the
Israeli army max Steinberg and Sean
Carmel II took part in the invasion of
Gaza they didn't get out alive a month
earlier muniya table salt huh from
Florida blew himself up at a Syrian army
checkpoint he was recruited by Al
Qaeda's Syrian affiliate al-nusra front
back in 2013
Omar Hammami of Alabama was killed in
Somalia he'd risen up so high in the
ranks of the al-shabaab group at the FBI
placed a five million dollar bounty on
his head
and historically Americans have been
involved in conflicts abroad for example
the Abraham Lincoln Brigade was made up
entirely of Americans fighting in the
Spanish Civil War
so is it legal for Americans to fight
for foreign armies well if you join a
group that the US has designated a
terrorist organization like al-nusrah Al
Shabaab the no it's not legal otherwise
you might be surprised to find that with
some caveats Americans are free to fight
abroad in 1967 the Supreme Court decided
that citizenship was a right that could
not be taken away even for serving in a
foreign army that is unless you fight
against the US which is considered
treason but what about dual citizenship
the US government says it understands
some of its citizens may have to do
military service for other countries but
it prefers they avoid it if possible so
what about groups like the Taliban which
the US doesn't officially list as a
terrorist organization well because the
US says it's hostile to it Americans
have gotten in trouble for signing up
for example John Walker Lindh the
so-called American Taliban claimed he
was simply joining a foreign army
without intending to fight the u.s. the
US government disagreed and Linda's
serving 20 years in jail on the flipside
can foreigners serve in the US military
yep about 4% of US soldiers aren't
American citizens but they do get a
fast-track of citizenship between 2002
and 2013 around 90,000 people serving in
the US Armed Forces became citizen
so what do you think about people
fighting for foreign armies and where do
you draw the line let us know subscribe
on YouTube follow us on Twitter and like
us on Facebook